bitter cold could for some cities to
change their New Year's plans Omaha
Nebraska is postponing its celebration
by a week Philadelphia is considering a
delay for the historic mummer's parade
but for cities like New York that are
going ahead with the festivities police
are taking unprecedented measures to
strengthen security Tony Tecopa was in
Times Square where up to two million
brave people are expected to gather Tony
good morning good morning it's important
to point out that the NYPD says there
are no specific direct threats against a
New Year's Eve celebration here in Times
Square but with two recent terror
attacks since Halloween the NYPD is also
putting together its strongest security
measures in years as New York City
prepares for its famed Times Square
celebration
the NYPD is taking no chances Police
Commissioner James O'Neill adamant
abundance of caution you'll see a
stronger police presence out there than
we've seen even in recent years heavy
weapons teams k9 units in aerial
spotters and snipers in hotels will help
protect the nearly two million people
watching the clock strike midnight
the increased measures follow a pipe
bomb explosion this month in a subway
passageway just steps from Times Square
and a truck attack on Halloween that
killed eight people and it take away
from our preparation is this people will
be safe and they should feel safe too
several cities around the country are
also stepping up their efforts the Los
Angeles Police Department says they will
have an increased visible police
presence in Miami random security checks
will be in place at its outdoor concert
in Bayfront Park and in Chicago extra
teams and salt trucks will be
strategically placed to prevent vehicle
attacks following October's deadly
shooting in Las Vegas 800 steel pylons
Plus snipers and twice as many Rapid
Response Teams will be there as
protection the Department of Homeland
Security gave the city its highest
security designation Clark County
Sheriff Joseph Lombardo as always law
enforcement can't do this alone
so I'm asking that while you are out and
join the festivities that you're also be
observant and notify police if you
notice anything suspicious and back here
in New York's Times Square the NYPD is
also shutting down 125 parking garages I
have an abundance of caution one more of
those new security measures markings on
the exterior some of these tall
buildings so in the event of a sniper
style attack the NYPD will be able to
identify the floor very quickly but
again no specific credible threat here
or any other city at this time Dana all
right Tony thank you